so I was born on April 5th in 1984 in
Memphis Tennessee
the land of the Memphis blues my father
was named after his father and I was
named after mine making me the third
member of my family to carry the Robert
Jefferson name my younger sister Libby
was born a year-and-a-half after me in
Memphis as well now my family moved
quite a bit in the first ten years of my
life or so we moved from Memphis to
Lexington Kentucky to Middletown Ohio
followed by Phoenix Arizona and we even
spent a really small amount of time with
my aunt and uncle in Palm Springs
California and so by the time I was
seven years old we had moved to Seattle
and for me these were some of the best
years of my life my mom always had this
extremely outgoing and adventurous
personality and I think it'd be fair to
say that she never really met a stranger
in her life and so when we moved to
Waterford Apartments in Kent Washington
in 1992 she immediately made friends and
I remember that one of the friends that
she had one of the people she met was a
woman named angel now angel was married
to Alonzo and they had a son named ace
who was about my age and much like me
and my dad ace was named after his dad
now looking back it's actually kind of
funny to me because where my mom was
really outgoing and adventurous I was
too but when I meet new people I tend to
get a little bit nervous and this was
really no different here and so I
actually kind of shied away from a
syndicate of entually I came around and
we became really fast friends now here's
the funny thing about the 1990s in the
90s we didn't have Xbox Live and we had
no PlayStation Network and we didn't
have steam and so if we wanted to hang
out with our friends we had to go over
to their house and play their game
console and so the funny thing was I had
a Super Nintendo and ace had a Sega
Genesis and so needless to say we spent
a lot of time at each other's houses
now there was this really funny time
when I lived in Seattle we had this fort
in the back of the apartment complex
myself ace and his cousin I think his
name is Marquis we would hang out all
the time we'd have fun we do kind of
chill in this for the neighborhood kids
would hang out with us too well there
was one day after to finish training
like it always does in Seattle and we
were playing in the fort and we got the
idea to swing off one of the branches
and so of course Marquis went and he
didn't have a problem he swung off the
branch and then ace went and he swung
off the ranch I was the king of bad luck
at that point in time and so I went to
swing off the branch and when I went to
go swing off the branch I lost my grip
and so as I started tumbling down I put
my arm down to basically brace my fall
and when I did I dislocated my elbow and
it was the most excruciating pain I'd
ever experienced in my life but it
tickled at the same time it was really
hard to describe and so I'm just
screaming I mean I'm just I'm probably
crying more due to panic because I don't
know what's going on in anything else
and I remember distinctly that ASA it
ace looked at my elbow and went oh and
so he's like I'm gonna go get Miss Cindy
so he runs back runs back to the
apartment to get my mom knocks on the
door within a few seconds although at
the time it probably felt like an
eternity I hear this screaming honey Bob
a mama bear was in panic mode she was
freaking out she came running screaming
by this point I bought out Andrew the
whole neighborhood with all my screaming
and hollering oh my my bellowing and
everything so she comes running down
picks up baby bear takes me back to the
apartment so we call the ambulance the
ambulance shows up takes me to the
hospital now at this time my family was
struggling financially
and so the biggest concern I think my
parents have the time was how are they
going to pay for the medical bills now I
didn't find out a lot of this stuff
until years later but what my mama told
me when I was much older was that when
they take me to the hospital to set my I
guess to to relocate my elbow I don't
really know how you would do the
opposite of dislocating but when they
tried to set it they ended up breaking
my arm and so as a result the hospital
paid for all the medical bills and and
yeah we were pretty much fine after that
now during this time while all this was
happening
my dad was a totally different kind of
person my dad spent all his time on his
food here when he wasn't working eating
sleeping or watching Star Trek The Next
Generation I guess he was in front of
his computer that's really all he did
and unfortunately what initially started
as a hobby or desire to learn about
computers turned into an obsession and
by the summer of 1995 it all boiled over
into the form of a wedge and the
marriage of my parents and so I remember
that my dad brought my sister and I into
the living room and asked us how he
would feel about moving back to
Lexington Kentucky initially I was so
excited because it would mean I would
get to see family that I'd only seen
rarely but once we arrived though things
really took a dark turn
see following the divorce of my parents
and my mom choosing to stay in Seattle
my dad became a very bitter man he hated
the world for his lot in life the
problem was that because my mom wasn't
in the picture the only people he could
take his anger out on where my sister
and I and sometimes he would use his
words but most of the time he would use
his fists now a couple of years after
moving back to Lexington my dad met a
woman named Anita and I don't really
want to sound dramatic here but Anita
was this bright light in this crappy
world my sister and I lived in and the
reason why was because when Anita was
around or when my dad was going to visit
her he was a totally different person he
was kind he was courteous or more
importantly he wasn't hitting or
screaming at me and my sister and so in
the summer of 1998 my dad bought plane
tickets for me and my sister to go see
my mom in Seattle and we were ecstatic
because we really hadn't heard that much
from her since my parents got divorced
we got maybe a birthday card the first
year but that was pretty much it we
really didn't hear anything from her
anymore at that point but unfortunately
my mom was in a relationship with a guy
who didn't who I guess really wasn't
what he made himself out to be but I'm
not going to go into a discussion about
that because
that's a really bad situation
you
buh-bye 1999 my mama moved back to
Lexington and I was a freshman at
Lafayette High School I had enrolled in
beginning voice chorus and apparently I
had inherited my mom's singing voice my
mom was an opera singer when she was in
college and honestly she had the most
beautiful voice that I had ever heard in
my life and my mom loved to listen to me
sing it was I don't know she loved
hearing me sing she said that I had such
an amazing voice but the problem was my
dad was looking to move closer to his I
guess his fiancee
at this point and so we uprooted I left
everything all my friends behind in
Lexington and Lafayette and we moved to
Northern Kentucky
now I lived there with my dad for about
a year so but I just never really fit in
I never really kind of I guess became
part of that group of people that
community and so ultimately I moved in
with my mom and I finished out high
school now in 2003 I started working at
the University of Kentucky and actually
worked there for about 11 years
and over these courses over the course
these eleven years these were probably
the most important years of my life and
the reason why was because I was so
naive going into this job but over the
eleven years I was there I learned so
many life lessons and one of the most
important lessons I learned was the
difference between adult decisions and
child decisions what I mean is that in
life I think we're presented with these
Forks in the road more or less and the
choices that we make when we come to
these forks of the road
determine what kind of person we grow
into and how we grow into that person my
job required that I work second and
third shift and so while my friends were
out partying while they were going to
bars I was working
and I used this time to expand my
horizons I use this time to start
reading books on philosophy and politics
and all these different things to more
or less broaden my horizons now
eventually I found myself enrolling in
college but the problem was that once I
enrolled in college it just wasn't a fit
I didn't really feel like I never really
felt like I belonged there of course I
mean I did great I got a 98% in my
calculus class I took some political
philosophy courses but for me it just
never seemed like it seemed like I would
I could always do something that didn't
require college I could go beyond this
archetype that a college degree was
necessary to achieve success in life but
there was a downside here
in 2010 my life took this drastic turn I
was at my mom's house and we were
planning to get dinner - that night we
would I usually go out to get dinner
once or twice a week and this was one of
those nights I was watching TV really
just kind of killing time waiting for
her to be ready but she was actually
waiting on a phone call because she was
expecting the result on a blood test for
a surgery she intended to have for her
knee she had really bad arthritis and so
once she got this phone call I remember
that she got extremely quiet and then
she said okay and so I asked her I said
you know hey what's what's going on you
know was that the doctor was that the
results and I'll never forget when she
turned and she looked to me she was
crushed and she was confused and she was
angry all the same time and then she
started crying uncontrollably and I said
what's wrong and she said she had cancer
and she ended up dying a year and a half
later
there's this some this Japanese poet or
there was he actually died in 1933 his
name was Kim Ji Miyazawa I think it was
anyone's said that to live on and the
hearts of others is to never truly die I
don't really know why I'm adding that in
here but I felt like I should
so by 2014 by January or so I started
this YouTube channel and those of you
guys who were around when this whole
YouTube channel first started although I
imagine with the changes that I've made
over the course of the last year and a
half or so there's probably not that
many left but you guys remember that
this whole YouTube channel was started
under the basis of making sense of the
Marvel Universe to non comic readers a
mom who is I guess a stay-at-home mom or
watches games or something like that
trying to look at rying to find a way to
identify with her son to find this
common ground with her son could watch
one of my videos and immediately
understand what the Avengers were about
and so when her son said I want to go
see The Avengers she would understand
why he loved the Avengers so much and as
time progressed you know so many of my
friends had said that I was so good at
teaching people things and so I just
started taking these elements and
incorporating them into my youtube
channel and the videos began to evolve
and the videos we can do to grow they
began to sort of take on a life of their
own and before I knew it I was in this
world of being a youtuber you know I met
Benny I met Sal and the YouTube Avengers
were born we had created this incredible
concept in the realm of YouTube we had
found ourselves bringing together all
these different comic book youtubers
together I guess you know creating this
community that was already in existence
just kind of fragmented you know and it
was it was so awesome to see this world
forming in front of our very eyes
watching a take place in real time
but in the same year last year tragedy
struck a second time
my stepmom I need a head called
my sister and I of course very my dad
had been married for quite some time at
this point and she said your dad's got
some news from the doctor you guys need
to come down to Tennessee because by
this point my dad and my stepmom had
moved down to to the city just outside
of Nashville and with this being three
years after my mom died my sister and I
were so sure my dad had cancer I mean we
figured that's I mean there's you know
what else could this be it was the first
thing that cropped up in our minds and
we were right
pancreatic cancer with a 95% mortality
rate within the first 10 years dad died
before the year was over
Oh
and so as it stands now YouTube is my
job I make videos for you fine people
explaining the intricate complexities of
comic books making sense of this
extremely daunting concept for newcomers
and providing a refreshing nostalgia
trip for older fans and before I in this
video I want to say this I don't
consider my life to be remarkable in any
real fashion I think my experiences fall
in line with the experiences of so many
others and this intertwining of life
experiences is a common ground that
reminds us that while we may come from
different backgrounds religious beliefs
or worldviews at the end of it all we're
all humans craving the same connection
to one another what we've built here
with this YouTube channel over the
course of the last year is a platform
for us to come together to share this
love for a similar thing comic books
more than that it's a chance for us to
cast aside our differences and to share
our fondness for a common concept and to
me that is one of the most remarkable
achievements that I think any of us
could have made in our lives with that
being said I want to thank everyone for
helping this channel grow to two hundred
thousand subscribers and I can't wait to
see where we go from here
Oh shadow the shadow
Oh
the shadow
do
now
Oh
you